[Music]
ah
it's it's that feeling i think that
feeling of what you
get from landing a skate trick and
the first time that happened to me i'm
still chasing that feeling 25 years
later
[Music]
i used to play the video games a lot
with my little brother so
i pretty much begged my mom for a board
and i just couldn't put it down i was
always outside playing with that board
everybody told me that i was gonna get
an opportunity to skate with tory
putwell
you know of course i got excited i've
been watching him skate
since i can remember you know what i
mean since i can't even
watch a skate video just to have the
opportunity to stay with him
is legendary in itself
[Music]
when i used to think about old-school
skateboarding like in california
the first thing that always pops into my
head is like lords of dog time
the old school generation that started
it they're still
doing it oh yeah so it's hard to say how
long you could be a skateboarder we
don't really know
to be a professional skateboarder living
with narcolepsy
you know there's struggles every day
realizing how important it is to be
healthy
to maintain my physical so my mental is
a leave so i'm well balanced from
skateboarding and you know especially
with me being narcoleptic my health is
is key focus
every time i kind of get back into the
skating
rhythm i always try to see if i can do
like a tre
flip so i can show you i'm thinking or
two about 360 flips let's do it
let's do it come on
any time that you you flip the board you
know you need to scoop it yeah your tray
flipping it's gonna go that way
jump with it keep your body right above
it yeah and i know you're gonna land it
where are you going to spin the board
just jump with it
stay with it
oh that's not going to cut it
oh yeah that was it
what is something that's been able to be
beneficial for you being on good
nutrition
yeah cutting down on sodium the more i
know about it the better it's gonna be
for me
to actually live my life cause it's it's
more than just the disorder
it's the risk that it could have on you
later down in life right
if i want to skateboard for the rest of
my life
[Music]
[Music]
remember you're not alone to learn more
about narcolepsy and long-term health
visit morethantire.com
you